[Música]
la asamblea nacional de Nicaragua aprobó
por unanimidad de enmiendas a la
Constitución y también a la ley de la
Policía Nacional con las que la
institución deja por ejemplo de ser a
política y a partidista queda sometida
al presidente de Daniel Ortega la nueva
normativa también castiga la deserción
de los uniformados para hablar de este
tema saludamos en Estados Unidos a
Elvira cuadra y es experta en temas de
seguridad y directora del centro de
estudios tras disciplinarios de
Centroamérica Elvira bienvenida directo
América
Muchas gracias Andrés una de las grandes
preguntas que tal vez se hace mucho es
porque un presidente que no tiene
oposición que controla el parlamento y
las instituciones del país tiene que
tomar una medida como esta que hay
detrás de la decisión de Ortega
detrás de esa decisión de reformar la
Constitución y la ley de la policía
lo que está es la imposición de un
estado policial de una política de
seguridad
orientada a vigilar y controlar todas
las expresiones de descontento que hay
en la población no hay oposición
organizada no hay espacio para eso pero
sí hay un enorme descontento de parte de
una mayoría de de la población en
Nicaragua eso es lo que lleva a Ortega a
avanzar en el control que tiene sobre la
institución policial ahora frente al
castigo contra los policías desertores
cree que se expone de algún modo un
posible debilitamiento del apoyo de la
fuerza pública hacia Daniel Ortega A qué
se debe esto
efectivamente Durante los últimos meses
se han conocido numerosos casos de
deserciones de efectivos policiales
algunos de ellos incluso han salido del
país hacia otros destinos para
escapar y no tener que prestar el
servicio y esto tiene que ver con que se
niegan a
actuar en esta política de seguridad que
mencionaba con anterioridad
ahora que cambia cuando una institución
como la policía pasa de ser controlada
por un director o un Ministerio de
defensa como pasa en muchos países a ser
controlada o subordinada a un presidente
y sobre todo sobre todo cuando se cambia
su estatus político y a partidista
pues la la reforma hace cambios que no
son menores hace cambio de fondo porque
la policía estaba definida como una como
un cuerpo armado de naturaleza civil y
ahora pasa a ser simplemente un cuerpo
armado quiere decir que tiene la
tendencia a ser una policía militarizada
no hay como en otros regímenes
democráticos un contrapeso de otras
instituciones civiles de otros poderes
civiles que supervisen y controlen la
las decisiones que se toman en relación
con la institución policial y queda
sometida o sujeta a la disposición que
emana directamente desde la presidencia
y en las calles por ejemplo Cómo
podríamos ver ese cambio
es muy probable que en las calles se vea
como un endurecimiento de los
dispositivos policiales mayor vigilancia
mayor control sobre los movimientos de
la población
ahora desde 2019 Elvira se ha reportado
por ejemplo como Daniel Ortega utilizado
a la policía para reprimir a sus
opositores a los manifestantes
empeorará ahora la percepción de
Seguridad Ciudadana y la desconfianza
hacia estos uniformados con estas nuevas
demandas
de hecho efectivamente la policía
hace algunos años tenía una opinión muy
favorable entre la población Y eso ha
venido cayendo en picada con todo lo que
ha sucedido desde el año 2018 hasta la
actualidad y la actuación que esa
institución ha tenido en ese contexto lo
que se espera es que esta reformas estos
cambios afecten todavía más esa
percepción ciudadana sobre la
institución e incremente en la
percepción de inseguridad y de temor
entre la población
bien llama la atención particularmente
Elvira uno de los artículos de la ley de
la policía que tiene que ver con el
incumplimiento de los deberes y lo voy a
leer aquí textualmente dice quien sin
justa causa desobedezca las órdenes de
sus superiores en perjuicio de la
Seguridad Ciudadana será sancionado con
una pena de seis meses a dos años de
prisión significa esto que ningún
uniformado puede negarse a nada que se
les pida a nada que le pida al
presidente Daniel Ortega
en efecto Ese es el espíritu que está
detrás de ese artículo que ha sido
incorporado a la ley de la policía
por eso decía hace un momento que
lo que se ha hecho es reforzar la línea
de mando La línea de autoridad que emana
desde la presidencia y que se ha
traducido en otras ocasiones
órdenes que incluso violan derechos
humanos y ciudadanos fundamentales en el
caso de Nicaragua y pues han habido
situaciones en las que los oficiales y
efectivos de policía se han negado a
cumplir esto lo que tiene es el
propósito de prevenir que
cuando se manden ese tipo de
órdenes Pues los policías no las cumplan
Elvira finalmente teniendo en cuenta
todas estas enmiendas todos estos
cambios castigos etcétera podría
interpretarse estaba como una medida
preventiva ante una eventual sublevación
de la fuerza pública
yo creo que detrás hay una un temor de
que esto pudiera ocurrir pero la esta
disposición tiene un
efecto este contrapuesto porque
sabemos que hay descontento entre las
filas policiales y que esta
estas disposiciones
incrementan ese descontento Mira Elvira
cuadra experta en temas de seguridad
directora del centro de estudios
transdisciplinarios o Centroamérica
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos con el
análisis aquí en directo América
Gracias que tenga un buen día y ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
sintonizarnos no se desconecten vamos a
hacer una breve pausa y ya regresamos
con este último bloque de directo
América
[Música]